this is not a test do not panic the
following message was transmitted at the
request of Marvel explained a point of
incursion has been discovered between DC
explained and Marvel explained to
prevent Marvel explained from being
destroyed DC explained will be rolled
into Marvel explained Marvel explained
will be renamed to comics explained once
again a point of incursion has been
discovered between DC explained and
Marvel explained to prevent Marvel
explained from being destroyed DC
explained will be rolled into Marvel
explained Marvel explained will be
renamed to comics explained thank you
for your time